Hello,
and welcome.
Hello.
How's it going, mate? Good. How are you?
I'm very well. Thank you. I'm feeling good.
I'm excited.
Yeah. It was fun last time. It
was. We
I feel we got quite far,
but the requests
were unanimous. People want to see how we
do this with Laravel
and all the bets that we didn't cover.
The bets we left to the reader's imagination,
if you will.
So are we assuming people saw the previous
session?
Yes.
Yes. We are assuming that people have seen
the previous session. Although, to be honest, we
are
it doesn't matter if it doesn't.
We will do our best to keep things
explained as we go along, and we are
starting with a Laravel project that has no
containerization
at all. So we are gonna be doing
a little bit of a repeat, but hopefully
much faster pace than last time with some
of the core steps.
And
how's your Laravel?
Non existent.
Wonderful.
Wonderful. Like,
few versions ago, I did the demo.
But Right. It's all sensible stuff, isn't it?
And I think a lot of the things
we're gonna talk about,
the general way you containerize things,
how you build assets,
how you do various things are gonna be
applicable across all projects, aren't they?
Yeah. Hopefully. Well well, that's
yeah. They will. They definitely will. I don't
think there's gonna be much super Laravel specific
stuff to how we how we can turn
Razer.
Yeah. Well, I mean, let's set the context
then for the people that are watching.
Okay. First and foremost, I'm gonna look away
from you so I can click over here.
We we are taking comments. If you wanna
ask any questions, if there's anything that we
don't explain very well, drop it into the
comment section on YouTube or Twitter. We'll keep
an eye on it. Also,
if you
need a nice, easy way to find these
streams in the future, you can go to
lot Rawkode.live.
And for anyone that wants to keep a
conversation going afterwards, there's a slash chat, which
is a Discord server. Feel free to come
and join us there and ask questions when
we're not streaming.
B, I'm getting better at this. Okay. Now
Now we're gonna set some more context about
what we're actually gonna do. So I am
just gonna pop open the share here,
and we have my screen. So
how did I pick the project to work
with today?
Simple. I went to github.com/topics/Laravel.
I filtered on PHP and most stars, and
I scrolled down this list until I find
a project that had no containerization whatsoever.
K.
So, obviously, we're not gonna do Laravel itself
because we're looking for a project that has
all of that
say through stuff, migrations,
asset completion, etcetera.
I did consider using this
Coel
project for music streaming. It looks really cool,
but I wanted something that hopefully more people
are actually using as a development platform rather
than maybe as a tool to consume where
you would just use Docker files anyway.
There's a few library based projects and projects,
and then I got the Flatum Flatum. I'm
not sure how to pronounce it, but I'm
sure I'll change it randomly as I go.
But this project looks cool. It's
like a forum,
retinal larval,
and it it
checked all my criteria. My criteria was no
containerization. You can see there's no Docker compose
here. There's no Docker file here. We get
to do everything ourselves.
Yeah. There's not much there, is there?
No. It's got
a pretty solid amount of stars. You know,
it's pushing on 11 k. It's got, you
know, over a thousand forks. Feels maybe got
a vibrant community contributor list. There's 20 contributors
down here. So PHP,
it's Laravel.
I mean, I think this is gonna be
a pretty cool project and a fun one
to hack on today.
But I have cloned it. So I just
did this a few moments ago. You can
see it's actually cloned here.
Alright. We've got the files. We're starting from
a fresh a fresh slate here. But, I
mean, I think I'm hoping
this is an I do a math, a
very Laravel,
I don't know, steady technical
application that we could just go from start
to production
and cover all of the steps that we
kind of plucked around last time.
So I guess what makes sense first is
to just copy what we did last time,
and that's what just get it running and
understand the steps that are
that we need to go through to make
that happen. That sound good? Yeah. And I
can see that they've got a installation guide.
Where we are going, we don't need guides.
Well, it's interesting to know what how they
say to install stuff, don't they? Alright. You
go your way.
I'll just I'll have a quick look and
see if there's any gotchas in it.
I'm just gonna run composer and so first.
Like,
let's let's see how far through this we
can get. You take a look at the
gate. The in fact, I'll pull up the
gate too. Let's do it.
Where's the installation gate then?
Is it here? Oh, there we go. Docs.florum.org.
Yeah.
Yeah. Click that.
So they give you installation on
Apache or NGINX.
You need something you need MySQL or MariaDB,
and they're specifying
particular version of PHP.
That's it.
Ideal.
So we have our first warning comment
from Alex
who has said that this does not look
like a standard Laravel application and that the
composer JSON doesn't even mention Laravel.
Now I did notice the lack of Laravel
adhere. I'm hoping that that it just encapsulated
in platinum core.
I know that's
an assumption, but I'm gonna clarify that now.
So
If you decompose an info in your shell,
does it have Laravel?
Yeah. There's loads of Laravel stuff in core.
So what was that command? How can I
confirm that here? Well Composer Composer info
after this. Yeah.
Let it install. See, but I could still
eliminate. I'm pretty sure that's a Laravel thing.
I can see
Yeah. I'm not seeing Laravel Laravel.
So your your concern is it might be
too nonstandard?
I wasn't concerned. Alex is now mainly concerned.
Yeah.
Within the first six minutes of the stream,
choose me.
So I guess the question for me is,
do you do things that a typical Laravel
project would do, for instance, to run migrations?
Okay. So if I grab composer info for
dash I Laravel
Mhmm.
So maybe they're just using a load of
Laravel bits.
That's frustrating.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now is there enough Laravel here for us
to continue?
No.
Illuminate is the database package,
so we can show migrations. Right? Even if
they're not Laravel specific, hopefully, that's not gonna
be too different.
Right. Okay. Right. Alex, you've been so Alex
has suggested we take a look at
anterior patent CRM. So we're gonna do
a last minute switch. What's the worst that
can happen?
And carrier Peng CRM.
Oh, and they actually alright. Okay.
Right. No Docker set up.
Alright, Alex. We'll do it. You have
persuaded us.
I mean, it's only got 670
stars.
What's the license?
The GitHub license?
That just means that everyone can use it.
Could it's something could
it's something that can't show on screen? Yeah.
That's fine.
Okay.
We've got installation instructions, MPM, composer. Okay. I'm
happy with that. So we've got some artisan
here, which I believe is the OLM
part of Laravel. So we will we'll put
it. Let's go for it.
So I will
clone this.
Artisan is like the task runner.
Okay. Task runner.
So let me pop that open.
It means I'm gonna kill this live share,
but I'll send you a new link in
case we need to do any pairing.
It should automatically copy to my clipboard. Copy.
Copy. Copy.
And we'll get started.
Alright.
So
I need to run composer install again. Wonderful.
Let's just
get a Docker Compose file started for now.
We get some of the boilerplate out of
the way. Yep.
We're gonna go with version two. I covered
this in the last session about why I
prefer version two over version three.
And and it's really because we want to
be able to orchestrate
our
we wanna be able to use health checks
to guarantee the order in which things are
starting. I I think
I I wouldn't spend five to ten minutes
to get over why that's important, you know,
as much as we want parity between our
development environment and our production environment.
Visit the workflows
with development and production are extremely different. So
watch the last video for for more information
on why version two is important.
We will call this service PHP.
I will just add a very base PHP
image for now. I'm not gonna do anything
else.
And I'm assuming we're going to need a
database.
Looks like it. Yeah.
Alright. We have another question
from Pierce. So are we taking a Laravel
app and building Docker into it?
Yeah. We are. We did the session last
week where we took a PHP application.
We showed how to build a development environment
using Docker Docker Compose, but then take that
automation and use that to build a Docker
image that can be shipped to Kubernetes on
production.
The feedback that we got is that people
wanna understand how to handle all of the
the
deployment steps that we cannot flock over. Database
migrations, asset compilation, and a few other recipes
running these tests. That's what we're gonna do
today. So we're gonna use Laravel.
We're gonna get development environment running with Docker
and Docker Compose again. We'll do that relatively
snappy, and then we'll start to talk about
the Kubernetes aspect and how we run those
migrations in a production like environment.
Yeah. It needs PHP 7.3
or better.
Yeah. So we're just on PHP seven, which
we cover as the latest anyway.
So you you don't you don't nail it
onto a specific one
for dev?
Yeah.
I should do this as if I was
doing this for production.
I will. Okay. So what I would normally
do is go to here,
Docker Hub, go to the PHP image.
I can set the cookies,
tags,
and
I thought we had a 7.4, but I
guess I was wrong. Yeah. There is. Seven
four out of time.
We were using last time.
But in a general sense, do you not
do you not specify a minor version? Would
would you
do you think it's important?
No.
So I like to take as many
updates as possible. So I don't commit lock
files, and I don't generally pen to minor
versions in a Docker
in a Docker container.
The reason why would be that
I always wanted to pull the latest and
greatest, and then I wanna trust
my continuous integration and deployment platforms to detect
when something goes wrong and block that pipeline
so that I can go and investigate and
fix it. Right. Which means if I do
pin to seven and seven point five came
out and there was some sort of regression,
my CI or my test would pick that
up,
and then I would be able to go
and make my code work with that latest
version rather than just pan into 7.4
and then 7.7
comes along. I've got three releases of things.
You know, that that surface have changed.
It's just much bigger, and I'd rather deal
with really small incremental continuous updates than large
ones.
But you gotta have to take one in
there.
Yeah. They would do try and sort of
lock everything to specific versions as a sort
of safety net, don't they?
But you're saying that the CI is it
okay to break the CI every so often?
Yeah. Definitely. You know, and then track your
continuous integration. Track your test. You know, if
you've got enough of that if you're getting
so much
ACG's or set one incidents or anything like
that because of that approach, then your test
coverage needs to improve, the automation needs to
improve. You know, there's
there are symptoms there that could be worked
on, and it doesn't mean that everyone can
take this approach that I have. I generally
I I think I spent and invest a
lot of time in the tooling to make
it work.
And it's a journey, so it's a scale
of zero to 10 and how close you
can get to that continuous automatic update. Okay.
It's not for everyone, but try and get
towards that stage, I think, is really important
because then your team can focus on the
more fun stuff.
Right. Let's
let's go with
I'm just gonna have a seven APM after
that.
Okay.
Now let's take a look at these installation
instructions again. We don't need to play with
them anymore. There's much there.
So there's NPM stuff.
So you run composer. You run NPM.
You use some database stuff that I think
assumes you've got a database.
Okay. So we're not gonna use SQLite as
the easy approach here. Let's
MySQL MariaDB Postgres.
Where where's your poison, Kieran? What do you
want? Don't mind.
MariaDB.
Believe it's version 10 currently.
Okay.
Now
we're
I can start filling in the environment that
we need to configure this.
But
let's just walk through those steps as well.
If I didn't know,
then I would come to the MirrorEye DB
image.
I can scroll down,
and, eventually, we'll get to these environment variables
that allow to configure how this runs.
So
we're gonna do a random password.
Nice.
I've never used that. Yeah.
It just means that we're gonna
force our automation to use a very specific
username and password that we also can better
for environment variables. This is how it would
run-in production. We wouldn't run necessarily with the
root user and our production DB, but I'm
not gonna do that here.
Which means we can now specify these two
fields, the username, password, and the database.
So we'll do that now.
Mhmm.
And we'll call the user
and CRM,
and the password is gonna be the same
CRM. Not very secure, but it's dev. It's
okay.
What else do we need?
Database. Okay.
We'll get the database and name.
Ping CRM?
Yeah. You got it.
So let me explain something else that's weird
about this configuration. The MariaDB container
image wants to be a drop in replacement
for Oracle's MySQL,
which is why these environment variables are called
MySQL.
So you can swap these out as you
wish, and they just work. Nice night.
Now that's the database configured.
So once we've run that, we'll have a
an application server,
an FPM server, and a database. We need
a web server.
Correct.
Well, we will need NGINX.
And
we're gonna make that available locally so that
we can actually browse through it.
We need our code
inside of this container. We wanna work in
there as that code. So these two go
great together. We can set the working directory,
which means if I exec into this container,
I'm gonna be next to the code where
I'm at it, which is also here.
What else does that PM require?
I'm assuming we're gonna have some cache and
logs to deal with, but
not sure what that looks like yet.
Yeah. We'll find out.
Alright. Well, why have I got a right.
Oh, okay. Because this is on a a
list. Okay.
Looks okay.
Yep.
Alright.
So Thomas is reaching out with a comment.
Using Docker plus b three would allow you
to use secrets and the MySQL password file.
Yeah. And there are just too many disadvantages.
Like, if I were to use version I
really recommend watching last week's video. It's at
Rawkode.live.
And
the steps that I would need to take
to orchestrate or or script around starting my
database container and then waiting for it to
be healthy to receive traffic and then spinning
up in the next to that game.
It's just it's just too much work. And
as much as I would like to use
the secrets locally,
I'm happy to have met that for an
environment that I can spin up with a
single command. And I think for developer onboarding
and quality of life and working on the
project at the end to end basis, that
is more important
than
consuming something like the secrets.
I think that's a good example of what
you were talking about, the version three is
more oriented towards deployment into prod as well
because
managing a secrets file is very much the
sort of thing you do wanna do in
production, but it can probably overkill for a
dev environment.
You can just set there's no point having
a MySQL secrets file that just has ping
CRM, ping CRM, ping CRM, and it's a
credential.
Yeah. My my goal is to
so our our number one objective is never
to break the parity between development and production
as far as operating system, dependencies,
extensions, if that's all. But when it comes
to the dev side, I want developer happiness
and experience. And when it comes to production,
I want security
and resiliency.
And Yeah. You know, those are I can't
have both of those at the same time.
And I'm not gonna settle for anything in
the middle that satisfies dev and prod. So
just separate workflows.
Appreciate that and make it work. Yep.
Cool. NGINX,
FPM,
MariaDB.
Think we're got a certain point.
Yeah. We need so we need an NGINX
config file, so NGINX can find FPM.
And we need to know how the PHP
app
connects to the database
so we can set some environment variables so
it can find the database.
Perfect.
So you're right. Let's get that engine x
config here. And they don't provide one, do
they? No. Laravel did. Just saying, guys. Let's
steal the Laravel one.
It was a dot fail. It's literally complicated,
though. Have you got the one from last
time?
I do have the one from last time.
Because we've had a very cut down one,
didn't we?
Okay. So that was under slimopsenginex.com.
I'll just copy that there for now, but
we now have our v host file here.
Which is very basic.
We might just need to change that. Do
we need to change that route path?
No. I'll just make sure that's where I'm
at.
We're not delivering any kind of thing yet.
We'll do that if we have to. I
don't think we I don't believe we have
to just yet. Okay. Let's
get this working there. So if we do
a volumes here, we mountourvehicles.com,
that's etcetera, nginx,
B
default.com.
We also need some dependencies.
So nginx
uses as you can see in this vhost.com,
nginx uses this host name of PHP, which
means if we remember from last time, that
container has to be created first.
Otherwise, that resolution will fail. Yeah. Because we're
using version two, we can take advantage of
the my editor seems to go that we
are going to this syntax.
PHP
open editor condition
service.
Now we don't need it to be healthy.
We just need it to be available for
the DNS resolution.
However,
our PHP application
has a dependency too,
which is gonna be MariaDB.
Mhmm.
And the condition here, we're gonna make service
healthy
because we're gonna automate
running
our
migrations.
Yeah.
Potentially.
Which means we need to add a help
check to this. So we can do a
help check,
We have a test.
We
use the shell syntax last time. We said
run bash
bash c. And this is a very crude
health check, but it's
fast.
We did
cat of
dev.
Oh,
is it P2P?
I'm gonna get this wrong.
C p o six.
Cat from or cat to?
You you're reading from it?
Yeah. I'm just trying to
I I could pretty much do a cat
or an echo to it. It'll fail as
that port isn't opened. I'll show how that
works in a second. We'll spin up my
container and actually run that command.
Do need an angle bracket in there?
Cut to
No. It should be okay with that. Let's
let's let's check it for it. So container
run.
You know, I'll enter active.
We're going into MariaDB
10,
and I will we'll just run bash.
Start Docker.
Why do I always forget to start Docker?
It'd be nice if the command line had
a do you want to start Docker?
Yes. That would be nice.
Alright. I'll just take a few seconds. I
mean, it's just because you've got a Mac.
Right? Like
Yeah. I keep debating them back to using
my my Linux machine for day to day,
but I just I'm trying to persevere with
the Mac right now.
So Alex has left another comment. Thank you
for making this interactive. It's more fun when
you leave comments. If you want standard NGINX
stuff for Laravel
Yeah.
Next?
I'm
hoping what you're trying to say there is
Laravel possibly has an NGINX virtual host. If
it does, drop the comment, and I'll I'll
just use their NGINX config straight up. If
we have any problems with it, I'll make
changes. I want this to be super Laravel
specific.
Send me a link, please. Okay. Let's run
this again.
And the syntax we're using is batch test
c cat dev p t p localhost
p t o six.
No such bad directory.
So I probably just got that wrong again.
It's a net.
Oh, I think it is p t p.
This is looking up from last time.
One day I'll remember that syntax. It's a
really cool hack though.
So Yeah. Because I've seen people running curl
and stuff, you know, and having to
put something like that into their image, whereas
this is bash built in stuff, isn't it?
Like cat. Yeah. It does. It's the TCP.
Well, but I did an echo instead of
the cat. Okay. Maybe that is important.
So echo
TCP
local host.
So
yeah. Because that's better. So what Bash does
is Bash provides
a virtualized TCP stack through dev slash TCP,
which means that you can
put in any IP address or or domain
name, like, .com/44three,
and it'll test if it's open. If you
don't get a response back like that, it
means it's listening,
and you can actually echo it as response
code. I wanna see whether Google is responding
on 1443,
then, you know, that's gonna change that.
The local host, you won't get a timeout.
You'll just get a direct error saying, hey.
What's happening?
Yep.
So only Bash provides that. I mean, if
you're using Alpine
as your base, I mean, she won't have
access to it unless you install Bash. But
it's a really nice, great way to do
sample port based health checks when that's all
that you need. And as we discovered last
week, MySQL and MariaDB only open the socket
when the database is ready to receive queries
or commands, which helps.
Very helpful.
Okay. So let's make that an echo
there.
So now we have a help check on
our MariaDB.
We can depend on it here.
Now what that means is that we now
have a single command to spin up all
of our services,
which should work.
PC is just an alias I have for
Docker Compose.
I should be able to run up.
Oh, yep. So two doesn't work. Has to
be 2.4.
And
it's not oh, it is test. Right? Command
or command shell.
No one ever remembered all these things. Okay.
Cool.
Okay.
So
for the environmental stuff, for PHP finding the
database, Laravel, I think, uses dot env often
for config
dot env files.
Alright.
So, yep, we have a dot env example.
Nice.
So those are the
there's the SQL. We'll
need to look at what the fuck I'm
looking at.
So that makes it
so
almost trivial to dockerize or containerize application.
You know, this is classic 12 factor manifesto
stuff. Been able to configure it each environment
through
environment configurations. It just makes everything a lot
easier, but that's great.
I must have been able to copy this
to be not a dot example.
So let's do that. Okay.
So all that started. That just means my
health check is working. Engine x can can
reach PHP as a DNS name and PHP
is
well, that won't be doing anything yet, so
PHP probably exit.
Well, I APM is ready to handle connections,
but I don't think we've we've told it
where to run around with that. So it's
probably not doing anything.
We should get What's the next step? Gonna
say you can see if we got the
hello world NGINX
page. Oh, yeah.
I'll just spin it up in the background.
We don't need to watch the logs right
now. So, I mean, I can leave it
running.
Mhmm.
So comment from Alex in the chat.
Yeah.
I actually see not not Alex, I see
people get confused about dot end versus real
environment variables.
And,
yeah, if if we're using Docker,
can specify all the config with our our
actual environment variables
and not have that dot in file. Right?
It so you can,
but it makes it a little bit more
difficult.
So let me clarify that. Now
I can't
I'm here, add environment,
and add
every variable that we need. The first problem
is
let's just do this.
I mean, that becomes unruly a certain number
of environment variables. And if we take a
look at this dot e n b,
there are a fair few.
And, also, I cannot reuse
this.
Now what I can do is use the
Docker Propose
e n b file
where I have a list, and I say
dot EMB. And that just means that if
I need to consume those environment variables in
another process, whether it be
imagine if we have I'm not sure what
Laravel uses for
job processing that has a different process that
runs. But, you know, if this is real,
it'd be like sidekick or something.
And it might need access to those environment
variables too. It just means I don't have
to duplicate it. But I generally prefer using
the dot e n b approach
and then just linking it together with it.
And then I wouldn't have these. It would
be better. I can't I conflict on it
with
I think Laravel does this and I know
Symphony does this. The frameworks then try and
read the dot end file directly
irrespective of whether they're in a Docker context
to find environment variables
aimed at dev dev type environments.
So I'm not aware of any
frameworks that would read the dot e n
v as part of their process.
What Laravel Maybe it's just maybe Laravel does
that. What most recommend is running a source
prior to running your commands to pull it
into the execution context. So I'm
not on as solid ground on Laravel, but
Symphony has a PHP component that will read
the dot end file
and set those environment variables in PHP
using PHP set end.
No. Not what you're doing. But, basically, it
sets them in the framework, and that some
can sometimes conflict with what you're doing in
your Docker Compose setup.
Okay.
So Let's let's see if we run into
that. I'm not sure what will happen. So
I tend to turn that stuff off,
basically, is what I'm gonna get to and
make it so that it's Docker that's reading
the environment variables.
I've pasted in.
It's it's pasted in twice because this sharing
isn't working, but you can see the commented
out
section.
It's pasted wrong. That's the MySQL
config.
Delete the bit up below.
It's put it in about eight times.
Okay.
This is weird. I'm working on that. There
we go.
Oh.
Oh, you're having it?
You're just making sure I have that. Right?
Yeah.
Alright. So our database host is MariaDB.
Our database is Ping CRM,
Ping CRM.
If he wants something specifically,
especially something like DB host, I'd be happier
having in the composed file
because then,
you know, that service name.
Yeah. The thing I think I'd be I'd
be happy to put them in the Docker
Compose.
Although, generally, what I would do is use
the for dev, I'd use the ENV.
Right.
And so that I can set them once.
In fact, that's a good example. Let's do
that.
But here, I've got this
year.
It's better when the configuration uses the same
names.
So I can see this is MariaDB,
my SQL
username.
Let's just copy this so we're not
I don't need to guess it. Okay.
So we have these now.
This also means that I can just consume
this in ENV here. Even though it's got
loads of stuff in it, the only best
I care about are
another thing we need is just that one
here. There's no point.
No. I don't think there's much point in
putting that in the dot e n b
because it's not consumed anywhere else.
And in fact, we could just split that
out so we're not having that we're not
loading on everything. So let's just do dot
e n b dot MariaDB.
That there.
And
we'll do dot MariaDB.
And then we can consume this file and
the FDM one as well.
Yep.
And then there's a third option, isn't there,
that Docker
compose will pick up that dot ENV file.
And you can use those variables in this
config file.
Oh, I wasn't aware that Docker compose would
parse a dot ENV, but you may be
right. It does. So if you for instance,
you could have it in environment. You could
have mys MySQL username
colon and then dollar
what what is in there
what the secret is in the dot e
v file.
Okay.
Cool. That's good for now.
So you can keep coming to chat.
Alex says Yeah. That's what that's what I
was supposed to do. Good good comment. So
I'm gonna remove these ones
there
and there,
and we're gonna change our configuration to use
the MySQL one. So where did you see
that there was config database?
Awesome.
And if I say There we go. So
I'm okay with that one being the same,
but we want to reuse.
Let's go.
Or
Yeah. Great.
Okay.
So MySQL,
that's user isn't
when I have to check, that's, like, 14
times. Okay. MySQL database user password.
User password database. User password database.
You Then do these ones because these are
unique.
Okay. I think we're good.
Which
means
we got DB connection, DB port. We've got
a reusable one here.
Now we can confirm all of this work
by spending all of that down.
We can do a Docker compose down dash
b.
What we would expect to see when we
do an up now is that MariaDB should
still be happy because it's consuming the configuration
from enb. MariaDB.
And our Laravel application, when we run any
sort of migration, should be happy too because
it's consuming the same setup.
We could change the interval. What's happening here
and why the MariaDB has taken
five to ten seconds or however long that
is is
and our health check
here.
We don't override the interval or how many
intervals we need for it to be considered
healthy, etcetera. So we could speed that up
by just changing that. But I'm I'm quite
happy with it's it's not taking too long.
Now if we run a PS, we can
see our health check now reports this as
healthy.
We have our NGINX healthy, and we have
our FPN
what we have up. Sorry.
What you wanted us to do was to
confirm.
That's that's
good. I'm happy with that. NGINX responding, but
we haven't actually given it anything to serve
yet.
Yeah. And
okay.
So
now we have another comment from Alex.
Four more comments, Alex, and we're just gonna
have you join the session. So
doing
this obviously makes it harder to change post
queries in the future.
I would take config changes, but that's fine
if you know what you're going to use.
No one actually changes database engines.
Okay. I'll leave that up. We can talk
about that for a little bit if you
want. Any thoughts on that, Kevin?
I have changed database engine.
I had a CTO say, good news. We've
we've decided to move from Oracle to MongoDB
once.
So that's a that's a good sign not
be a trivial change either.
It's gonna save us a lot of money
there, is the sale. Yeah. Licensing is a
lot better.
Yeah.
I feel like we're we're changing things in
lot of places.
So I guess looks like Laravel has that
two layers of environment variables,
and then that config file is mapping the
how you're using the environment variables to the
real config.
And we've another layer of indirection going in
the Docker compose. So you can probably rip
it all out and make it very simple,
couldn't you?
You you probably have in the end file
my
my database password.
And what pretty much actually simplify
by using a DSM.
So another nice way of handling this kind
of thing is to make make it so
there's only one
config key for the database connection
by having a URL like
protocol for it. I've seen that for databases,
queues,
etcetera.
So am I correct in saying what you
and Alex are both worried about is
I modified
this file. Right? Yeah.
Okay. So let let's not change it. Which
is sounds like fine if you know what
you're doing.
Okay. So let's not change that file. Now
the only reason I changed that is because
enter dot e m v dot MariaDB,
we have these variables available to us. So
let's put this back to what Laravel expects
then,
and then we'll change it on the the
database side, which I guess is actually cleaner
because we're not
our cases are in a single location. So
what we can just do here is say
this is equal to
DB username,
password,
DB password,
and we can set my SQL database.
That DB database.
And that should still work.
We're not past that even on the Laravel
side. Yes. That's I think that's actually much
nicer. I think that's a good idea.
Let's
make sure it was not broken.
I can't see what it's doing.
Can't see me.
What? You can't see yourself?
When there's a comment up.
Oh, that's a shame.
Oh, no. There you go.
He's about to just try and pick up
above the comment. It looks like there's a
typo there, doesn't it? DB data database.
Yeah.
It's not the best name.
Alright. So we got Sorry.
Wrong in all the places.
Okay. So the my the database is still
happy,
and we could just confirm that we can
connect to that now. So let's do a
DC EXE.
I'm not gonna spend any more time on
this because I think that's been a while
now.
Go inside of our DB container.
Oh, yeah. You can't do dash IT on
top of ComposeExec.
We do it for you.
But we should be able to run MySQL
host one two seven
as user ping CRM password
and then the database ping CRM.
What did I get wrong there?
You've got database spelled wrong in some of
the places
in the
variable.
As long as it's only in that place,
it should work.
You're supposed to tell everything.
I did. I tried to, but
I said it wrong.
Okay.
One more time.
So that Python dot end stuff is from
Docker Compose trying to read the end file.
So yeah.
Docker report there's actually a weird thing, and
I can't remember the specifics of it it
because I tried to avoid the syntax anymore.
But to use the Docker Compose
one, I think you need the export.
It's a bit weird. We'll deal with that
if we have to. Let's see what happens.
As long as this works, we can move
on to the next
Alright. So let's just check we have what
we expect. So I I would expect to
see a bunch of these. Okay. That's not
work.
But that's our challenge then.
Let's see. Do we have our DB underscores?
No. Okay. So that is
that really annoying thing with Docker then. So
I probably
let me show you what I mean.
Docker
is a bit annoying and that
I believe it expects this syntax.
Which I bet you is not gonna work
with the dot ENP and the the
Laravel sites.
Rather than me fighting with it, I think
we'll probably just stick it all in the
Docker compose file for now. You
haven't
got
you haven't got those variables defined in the
dot ENV, have you?
They're defined here. Right?
And where is that referenced?
In my Docker compose file
here.
That no. That won't work. So
the way it works is your n file
setting
go back to the compose file.
Your n file setting means those environment variables
will be defined in the container.
So I would expect the DB one.
The
in in your environment stanza, you're expanding variables.
Those variables would come from dot env only.
Yeah. It works now.
Yeah. Okay. That's all working. That won't work
is what I'm trying to say.
Right. Anyway, we could You can't use variables
in the in the Docker Compose YAML.
The end file is sourcing them into the
into the running container.
It's not making them available while passing the
YAML.
If you want them available while the YAML
is being expand being expanded,
you have to put them in dot env.
Gotcha.
Gotcha. Gotcha. Gotcha. Okay. But then also expects
the six port syntax rather than
I've got to be honest, I haven't used
in far much.
So
let's test the hypothesis.
Oh, no. The problem is I had
cool on. The expert probably wasn't I'm just
being really dafted there. I had the b
username. I had the YAML syntax. I would
say it's dot net detail.
Yeah.
I know.
Right. Okay.
You're saying that I put this here. We'll
get the expansion. Let's just remove this dot
one for now, and let's confirm that
these weird weird things.
Correct.
Did you just take it out of the
dot env again?
Alright.
Thought you said apart this one automatically. No?
Yeah. Without you putting in file in. But
did you delete are those variables defined in
dot env? Yeah. They are.
Okay. I've moved them I've them all to
dot in. Let's just
if it's something right.
Oh, that should be
Okay.
Really gonna change that interval now. So
interval.
One sec.
Interval.
That's not last week. Okay.
So
what we just wanna confirm here then before
we actually do something a bit more interesting
is those environment variables are set, and I
can log in to my sql slash berated
b.
Okay.
That works.
So I can do one two seven.
Ping CRM.
K.
Alright. Next. I think it protected that password
even though it's ping CRM.
Okay.
So something
that
we didn't touch on last week is what
is our okay. We haven't configured FPM.
So let's go inside of our FPM
container.
They call it Laravel. There
we go.
Where does that live?
Is it
user of our HTML or something like that?
Docker Docker file?
Because we're mapping our code to slash code,
and that location is not correct. So let's
just
Yeah.
So the FPR.
What's the Apache stuff you're doing?
Let's just look it up from last week.
Okay.
Slim.
Let me modify it here.
For our w w h t m l.
Make sure we could have guessed that. Nope.
Okay.
Slash prop slash one cat command line.
So we use catlocaletcppipm.com.
That's a really cool hack, actually.
Whenever you're in a container, slash prog slash
one is always the running or primary process.
And if you just tap the command line
fail, you can see what the entry point
was.
Save my bacon a few times now.
So that is our default FPM configuration,
and we're just looking for
What are you looking for?
Just a rip, which currently is in
maybe it's in this dot d directory.
Are you trying to change the config to
point to slash code rather than
I just wanna know how that is.
So,
yeah, so I can get the directory.
So I'll tell you so I just read
the read me and put it in the
place they tell me to and try not
to look at how any of it works.
There's a fun in that.
We've got a whole bunch of different things
here.
Let's do www.com.
You can see some environment variables being set.
You can see
share route is not set. No. That doesn't
mean it's the web route
or the whatever
they call it.
Let's see if I can grab this.
What I'm lost what you're trying to do.
I want to know where it expects the
PHP files to live.
We saw that as var w w HTML.
But But that directory doesn't exist, which made
me think it was lying.
Isn't
it just because you have to mount it
in
or copy it in?
Hang on. Let's just go to Dockerfile.
Okay.
I couldn't grab an FPM one. That was
unfortunate.
FPM.
Worked there. Yeah. It's part of the. Okay.
It just doesn't exist. So
we can mount our code. We'll just leverage
that.
So
we will change the working directory.
Now
we need to serve
public h two. So I see the same
as what we did last week, but we
need to modify our index configuration.
Try to get lost.
Yes. It's still comfy.
And this will just need to match public
pixel.
Right.
We will recreate what needs to be created.
Got some interesting questions in the chat
about how do you maybe we'll come on
to this. How do you run typical sort
of development commands
in a dev environment?
I think that. We'll definitely We're right there.
I
use a pattern called
deshell, so I'll show you what that looks
like.
Okay. Good.
I mean, it's it's failing, but that's okay
because we haven't followed the installation instructions,
which means we do now have commands that
we need to run as part of the
installation, which means we need to develop an
environment. Now
whenever you type PHP or Composer here,
to me, that's a a warning sign. We
wanna avoid that as much as possible because
we're running those commands in
an environment that does not have parity with
production.
But how do we change that?
What I normally do is
build a development workflow.
It looks like so. So my entry point
is now going to be bash.
Okay. We'll do this to our make target.
A little bit later.
There's no make fail in this project.
That's where projects kinda make fail.
I generally add a deshell target, and the
goal being I wanna be able to say
make deshell in a terminal and get
interactive development environment that I can work with,
which means what we're going to do is
do Docker
Docker
compose
run
service ports. And I'll explain what these flags
do in just a moment.
I just wanna keep adding those things.
It's really annoying.
Run service port slash slash r m.
PHP is the service that we want to
run.
I'm also going to override the entry point
to be batch.
Mhmm.
And don't think I need
IT.
I do not. Okay. So I don't know
what service points does, service ports.
Yes.
So
when I do a Docker Compose run,
which means I want to run an individual
service here. Mhmm.
It does not publish those ports.
Mhmm.
When I tell it to when I add
service ports, it will just make sure that
the ports are exposed. Now, actually, I'm not
exposing FPM locally, but I'm so I'm just
gonna keep the flag there because that's important
for most applications and may become important.
I override the entry point so it doesn't
run FPM.
So what that means now is when I
run make b shell
yeah. Make files are fun. So we need
a dot phony
b shell.
That's basics or tabs.
And there's no edit or oh, there is.
We've got it already. Okay.
Make file
and then style
tab
and then size for
we save the style.
I hate make.
It does have I really wish it doesn't
have that pain point of tabs and spaces,
but doesn't matter. So what happened here is
we ran PHP.
It started MariaDB because of this dependency.
It hasn't started in Genet, which I didn't
think would well, I said that it's fake
encounter, but it makes sense. So we'll fix
that in a minute.
We don't have anything running here, which means
which means I need to add one step
here
up NGINX background.
Just because we can't have a separate dependency,
so I can't start PHP
because NGINX depends on it. So we just
have to make that a bit special. Let's
run that again. NGINX is up. FTM is
up. Now if I run here,
it's gonna time out and fail.
Oh, it didn't.
Oh, because I still got it running.
Shut that down.
And they'll make these shell. So, like, in
a fresh environment with nothing running, I would
run this command. It starts engine x, starts
where you need to be, basically, an interactive
terminal.
I can have go here
by the
Starting
NGINX is starting because of the dependency.
Funny. Because you're doing compose Docker compose up
dash d NGINX before you
Yes.
Alright. That's that's that's good. Okay. Doesn't matter.
So
now we need now we have an environment
which is production like web files.
I'm not gonna have composer,
so we need to fix that. So this
isn't
the
is this the
have we run a new copy of that
service?
Yeah. There'll be two running right now. So
let's Two running. Jump out here, go to
my directory, PHP examples.
And we're relying on the fact that they
share a volume. Right?
But if I run v c p x
But
this is the actual service that was started
by the Internet's dependency.
Yeah.
And this is my run container.
They're both interacting. This is consider right now
is horizontally scaled.
We can still run our migration path and
asset compilations.
They're both using the same volume, and so
I don't foresee any problems right now. And
we could remove that this one here
by just having an exit zero in the
Docker compose file, But it's it's really not
that important.
Yeah. It makes sense.
So
yeah.
So we can do all the typical stuff
because
all the things you want to do are
either creating files
in the volume or probably doing stuff in
the database.
Oh,
yeah. Definitely. So
right now, we need to fix the composer
thing. Like, if I'm saying I don't want
to run composer install locally because maybe there's
dependencies on extensions
that which would fail locally, then I have
to do that inside of the container. And
right now, we don't even have access to
composer, so we need to fix that. And
the way that we do that is the
same as last week too, where we have
multi layer files.
So we're gonna say
PS code that is particularly right.
We'll call this our base.
Mhmm. We're not we're not gonna do anything
with. We're just removing the duplication of base
image. Then we have dev
where we add the tooling that we need.
So I can do
APK. I don't know where I'm doing nothing.
I can do an app update and app
install.
Let's just stick in them there.
Okay. And
we're also going to copy composer from the
official image. And
if we remember correctly,
last week, it is available under user.
Let's just try and compose our user.
May be local, but I can't remember.
We can come back out here
and instead of using this, we're gonna say
that we wish to build an image,
the context of the current directory, and we're
gonna target that dev layer that has all
of our wonderful tooling that we need.
Makes sense? Yeah.
K.
So now It's also gonna affect the running
FPM. Right? So we've we're making it even
more explicit that our our composed file is
for dev.
Oh, yeah. Totally. Yeah. Post files should never
be used in production.
Let's get to Docker Post files.
I mean, there are people out there who
say Docker Post can be used in production
with version three. And if you're happy with
that, by all means. But
Uh-huh. It's
not for me.
So this installation of app is gonna be
cached. Right? Because
we're pulling we're copying stuff from the composer
image, which is always gonna be cacheable.
And then we do
Okay. So let's go back into our d
shell.
We now have the ability to run Docker
Compose
install.
And now you can see the the the
problem,
right, is that my local environment magically seems
to have some extensions that are required
by
this application that aren't available in my production
environment, which is this container.
So we we need to fix that. So
we need
these two extensions.
And
the Dockerfile provides a whole bunch of different
helpers to do that. So
and we can do run.
And then we've got PHP
what's it called?
I'm just looking out.
Docker PHP extension install. There we go. Does
this help a script
where we can do EXT XF and EXT
GP?
You spelled XF wrong?
Mhmm.
That's
a lot of it, but I don't know
if it worked and didn't work.
Stop refreshing. I I don't think you need
the the access and GD.
There we go. And then we can copy
that command to our base image. So Docker,
p t, x k, install, GD,
That's a zlib or zlib c.
So
and does that help?
It's our dev package.
Let's work out this dependency.
Maybe I should just quickly Google it.
Zedlib g zedlib one g?
Yeah. That might be it. We'll try that.
And if not, we'll just look it up
very quickly.
That's what That's what Google says.
And
this interactive environment is is good for this
because we can test this works before we
rebuild the image.
Alright. Okay. So, like, we got past that.
So let's add that first. So our base
image now needs this app update
and app install
dev.
Oh, what was that? One g.
Yep. One g dev.
We also need some sort of PNG one.
So let's do the PNG.
It's a dev.
A PNG dev.
And now we're codifying everything that we need.
It's it's good.
More works on my machine nonsense.
So in terms of wanting
the
latest versions of things,
how do you how
because this is something I've wanted to ask
before, actually. When when you've got your app
update at the start,
that's gonna be cached. So
it's
every time I build the container, it's not
going to do apt update?
No. But this base image,
you know, our continuous integration system is is
gonna force a rebuild to this on a
regular cadence, either every twenty four hours or
maybe once a week depending on how frequently
your deploys are. You know, that cadence is
really coming down to each team.
But, yeah, the I mean, the the challenge
being is that if you have a base
layer like this and you never rebuild it,
then your dependencies, your security patches, all of
that become very dated very quickly. And then
you'd have to build that.
You'd have your tooling force to sort of
uncached build every so often.
Yeah.
Use cache builds during nine till five, and
then at 3AM every morning, have an uncached
build run to make sure you're always up
to date.
Right.
Okay. So
That's a good now.
Yeah.
So the reason I say nine to five
use cash bills is that, you know, if
you're shipping and building regularly during the day,
you don't want your developers sitting waiting any
amount of time that you don't have to.
And it depends how slow your builds are.
If your builds are under a few minutes,
never use cache.
Yeah.
Just make sure people are productive during the
day. You don't want them to set and
sort of tighten because of compilation step.
Yeah.
But we've got that safety net that if
there's a critical security vulnerability in Zedlib,
we're gonna get the fix at some point.
Exactly.
And the composer install hasn't failed with the
extensions. We now have a container and production
environment that has everything we need about this
application.
And
we can cache that composer step as well
as we we did
last week where we say, okay. We don't
modify
what's our build JSON that often. So we're
gonna copy that to our working directory.
Mhmm.
And we can put this but I'm just
moving these steps up because
even if this does change, we don't need
to reinstall these two dependencies.
So we use the cache there.
And we're doing a composer install,
and that becomes part of our build process.
That means if we do modify your composer
dot JSON, you just have to rebuild this
image to get the latest dependencies.
Okay.
But currently, we're mounting
of local vendor folder over the vendor folder
in the image anyway.
Yeah. There's a lot of that hoops you
would have to run around actually to take
that up.
Which I do because I'm like, you're using
a Mac.
And the less files mounted, the better. So
for some big projects, they end up just
mounting instead of mounting everything,
might mount the the app folder.
We'll
we'll we'll come back to that. Like, I
mean, we could spend at least
an hour just covering that, especially on a
Mac because it is very weird.
But let's not
we'll come back to that maybe next week
on our session.
Let's try and actually get this running. We're
at over ten minutes, and we haven't got
it running yet. So installation steps.
So let's expect us to run this generate
command.
So we're gonna qualify that in our make
file.
So let's call this setup.
Why else do we need
migrate?
Collaboration expired. Right.
And we'll be okay with that.
We need to see their database.
Mhmm.
And
we can run star,
but we'll actually call this
run.
That's the web server, isn't it? I I
think so.
So we've got engine x already. We don't
need that.
Okay.
So
let's do make setup. So we're still inside
our d shell environment, which is our interactive
dev environment.
Hopefully, all these commands
just work, which, of course, never gonna be
the case.
So if I run if I run make
setup from the host, it's gonna fail?
Well, I wouldn't be able to find the
database.
Because maybe I haven't got PHP installed.
Or MariaDB running.
You're always you're always running make d shell
and then using it inside the d inside
the d shell.
Right. So it says it wasn't able to
find our driver. Does that make sense? We
haven't installed the MySQL driver as part of
our Docker file setup because it was it
must be an optional dependency in the composer
dot JSON because you might not be using
a MySQL compatible
database.
So we just need to hear
I think it's just called MySQL.
You think that's right?
Is that what the error message said?
Yeah. It couldn't find the the driver for
connecting to the database.
PDO MySQL.
So we
need to enable that.
As a downstream
product here and I know what database technology
we're gonna use, I could come in here
and just enforce that at the compilation step.
Where's the extensions? To
the top.
There you go. Line 30.
So
we could just codify that pixel.
Mhmm.
Let's just turn them.
Let me come back into our d shell,
and we can run setup. And, hopefully, it's
a little bit happier.
It is happier, but it's still not working.
So connection refused. So let's check our configuration.
So FPM doesn't have any config. So that
is a full part on our part.
Oh, yeah. We haven't set it.
We only set it inside the MySQL.
Let's make one more.
I got Phoebe. That's the one.
Okay. Lucky.
Okay.
What have we got wrong here?
Our database
where's our post?
I think Alex said that in the chat
about an hour ago.
12:12 fifty.
Alex said, I think we're missing DB host.
Okay.
Host.
Not host name.
You saw nothing. Okay.
Okay. So the migration ran.
Database was CD'd.
So
asset compilation.
Is that what that means? Is that what
makes sense? Right? Yeah. I think so.
So the in the instructions, there was a
couple of NPM commands ahead above what we
did.
Alright. Okay. So we need an
NPM CI to install the dependencies
and an NPM
run dev to build our assets.
Okay. So
there there's
half a dozen ways
to do this. So a
lot of these things,
we're we're treating them as
ad hoc one off things you do in
your dev environment. So, you know, seeding the
database, running
there's actually two let's split them into two.
There's things you only do in dev. Seeding
seeding the database isn't something you're doing in
prod.
Right?
Running migrations is maybe something we're gonna do
in prod.
Yep. And building the pipeline at that kind
of build step, that feels like something we
should be doing as we build the image
almost.
Yeah. There so I think the two ways
we'll try and cover that is the one
you just which is whereas maybe as a
PHP developer, I'm not gonna touch the the
front end assets or like that. And I
can make that into the image, but I'm
not gonna change. But I think there's the
other end of that where
maybe we are changing the assets as part
of our development workflow. We we still want
that to work too.
So
let's do
let's go with the naive approach in that.
We're not gonna change these assets.
And if I'm not gonna change the assets,
that means I can ship them in the
NGINX image if I want.
I mean, if anyone's getting any strong opinions
and, like, again, we're both not Hirevel developers.
That's best. Maybe maybe our is not the
one to listen to. What
what I suspect is gonna happen is the
mix
like Symphony webpack encore.
There there will be end up being some
interaction between the PHP framework and the static
assets. Like, it'll check for there
or
do you know what I mean? It'll it'll
it'll want to
have access to them in the PHP image.
That's my prediction.
So okay. So let's make this the easiest
way. As as part of setup, we run
an MPM
CI, and we run an MPM
run dev.
Mhmm.
That this is the naive. Let's get it
going, and then we'll see how we can
optimize it. Now the first challenge is we
don't have access to MPM inside of our
dev base layer image, but we can fix
that.
I
believe.
Install
Node. Js and NPM.
Obviously, I'm not entirely comfortable with
leveraging
dev images
super repository or at least a super image
with loads of stuff in it. So we'll
maybe try and see if we can clean
that up. But it does mean that I
can run MPM CI.
It should just work.
And I think what we'll do is we'll
just prove this works.
We'll take it away, and we'll bake this
into the engine x data things. I really
I think I do feel quite strongly
that NGINX should be serving the static assets.
The build process should be part of that
image build. And if they change, I'm just
gonna force a rebuild. I mean, the development
workflow for working on PHP versus working on
the static assets would probably
again, maybe I'm just not the person with
the experience
to indicate how the workflow should work. Yeah.
The front end developer's gonna want,
you know, what wanting to be watching the
file system and rebuilding if things change and
all that stuff, which might lead them towards
running that stuff locally.
So we can we can we can make
it work that way. Do some do some
do some some
me, I just want all all the stuff
built so I can work on the PHP.
So would that be a an m a
node build step?
I'd probably add another container to handle that.
It'll this MPM run dev seems like it's
actually running a web server
it's gonna start doing something in a moment.
Oh, no. It's building. Okay. These
things take time.
It's a lot of files, so it's probably
quite slow with volume amounts.
That's true. Wouldn't have that problem on Linux.
What do call them? Host mounts?
Host volumes.
Yeah. A bank mount or a host mount.
A what? A bank mount or a host
mount. Bank mount.
Okay.
Because there's been some chat about slow slow
max. It's that. Right? It's having lots of
files mounted.
Cool.
So let's see what happens. That'd
It's doing something.
It was doing something.
Alright. Well, again, some sort of four zero
four, so let's just see what's failing.
CSS.
Okay. Yes.
So
let's check our engine x
config.
So where does that
JS file come from? App dot CSS. Well,
I can't see that file.
It could be in public
It's there.
Okay.
So I'm assuming
there is some sort of redirect magic
on the APM
site.
They should be looking for that stuff in
that directory.
Let's go to index on PHP.
I wonder if Laravel should be handling this.
You'd you'd not want it to, would you?
No. That just outputs everything under resources.
Or not because the CS is under app
CSS, but the path is just here. Let
me check that.
No. No. CSS, app CSS. Yeah. So we
wanna serve that resources to retro as a
root fail system from NGINX, probably.
That's kind of the vibe I'm getting. Have
a look in the public folder and check
there isn't a sort of sneaky SIM link
or
Ah, there's an h t access.
It's a CSS folder there, isn't it? But
is it
It just pushes over her through index dot
PHP, which makes me think Laravel is trying
to handle that, and then it's
failing.
No. That that's in that in that h
t access, it's only applying
it's only requests that don't hit a file
or a directory going to PHP.
Yeah. But a request for slash CSS slash
app CSS
is gonna go be routed through index of
PHP because it doesn't exist.
That is that CSS folder in public empty?
Oh, record. Oh, okay.
Well, so what's going on here then if
I do public?
Is there any So development development and resources.
So maybe that's just with 11, and it
gets compiled into public CSS.
Alex says that Laravel does not handle the
CSS checks.
So let's
try.
But we're serving everything from oh, no. Right.
Okay.
So I think the problem is is that
request is coming in for app dot CSS.
Our engine x configuration at the moment is
configured
through everything through the index dot g s,
and then that's failing.
Now, let's just see if there is
engine x for
Laravel apps.
We thought we'd have done that. Rather, I
was trying to So you think all requests
are going through to PHP?
It is definitely. Yeah.
Right.
So we just want someone we just want
our production
engine x config.
Yeah. Looks good.
Or we could just make that those assets
available in in the NGINX site, and we
set them over NGINX.
I still feel that that's the right way.
That would make more sense, wouldn't it?
Let's have NGINX server.
Okay.
So how do we do that?
Lead volume?
Well, yeah. Okay. That was naive approach. Why
not?
Thanks.
And that in a nice possible way, of
course. I know.
So that should just take everything from here.
The the challenge would be the index. Php
would exist.
Very naive approach.
Let's see if that fixes engine x.
Let's just
use a second terminal.
Oh, I wanna restart
the engine next.
What that should mean is if I go
inside the engine container
did I not mention it?
Or w w HTML.
Oh,
r m engine x.
Help.
Still there?
Down? There we go. Stop it.
Stop it and force it. Right? Okay. And
then
start and
run up.
I should have the note.
K. So now it should
Mhmm. Be able to deliver those asset.
Well, then now we have the 403 problem,
which we got last week as well. And
then I believe it's just because that public
directory.
The
permissions on it? I don't think it's permissions.
I think it's that it doesn't exist.
See what happens if we do that. Is
it gonna be trial and error? Stop.
R
m s f. Engine eight.
I'm not back.
Definitely a four zero three.
And the problem is
that is for bettering.
So it's try because the public folder does
exist, does that mean it's not passing things
on to
FBM?
Is that our config?
So this should be running as
Alex has some pertinent comments in the chat.
Did I manage it to the wrong location?
No.
What does our vhost.com
look like? Can we remind ourselves?
Mhmm.
Oh, wait. No. That's right. Because that's still
the.
Yeah.
So I was trying to access the file.
I can't get a directory listed in that,
which makes me you know, the seems like
it's permissions.
I can access
that.
And so I'm assuming I could probably access
So the challenge is just the PHP fail.
So what I need to do
It's close. What's the what's the problem?
The problem is let's add
pick it up. Okay. So adding the index
dot HTML at least goes with the the
error. The problem is now that fail exists.
So it's when when you go into slash,
it's because the public folder
because the folder exists in the NGINX volume
now
Yep. It's trying to serve the directory index
of that folder rather than asking FPM for
it. Correct. And then something else has turned
off directory indexing.
Is that right? Yes.
But it's trying to deliver
it's trying to find the root fail, which
doesn't exist.
And which should be gone through the PHP,
but I think we need to add something
specific. So what was that? Root file does
exist. It's the folder.
And then the root had public.
He's saying if we do that, it should
work.
It's a good thing people watch this thing.
Alright.
Let's see if he sees
our end.
So we're gonna restart with that. Now let's
confirm.
Yeah. That doesn't work.
So we've broken that.
It's not that we wanna add a public
here. It's that
Stan just used the official engine x thing.
Well, let let's do that.
And look at why it works and ours
doesn't.
Okay.
Wonder if it's that, the little cheeky head.
No. I was like, ah, that's what it
is.
That one thing failed. Right? Then I'll copy
the failed, but, you know, I do I
I need to confirm it from my own.
The problem is it's looking for an index,
HTML. It can't get a direct to the
list of them, but we can just save
the index as a PHP file, which forces
it through this route.
Mhmm. Thanks.
K. That works,
and this will work.
Alright. I'll copy the file.
Copy the whole file.
So it was pretty
We're getting bugged down in NGINX.
If this works, let's never Yeah. Talk about
it again. That's just not important. You're right.
It's not an NGINX stream.
Not using a UNX socket. We're using
I should've kept that lane.
I think that should be alright. Okay.
CSS is working.
Fail not found here.
Oh, no.
Oh, come on.
It's good that we've got that confidence each
time.
Oh,
see, that seems like I didn't wanna copy
this nonsense. Okay.
W w w dot
It's wrong.
Primary script name unknown.
And because
it should be okay.
Does the server name
have to be there?
I feel like I was closer with my
own fail.
For better now, specs, the CSS works.
For better now, it's because they're trying to
access the root file. So
that should be enough to tell it not
to look for an index by HTML. And
if that doesn't work, we'll fix it.
K. So now we're getting a fail not
found.
Let's try
written errors through PHP,
which we had an example up here.
Public. We getting we are getting a four
zero four. Yeah. They're not there.
We shouldn't use a public. We just wanna
force it to go through PHP so it
goes to the FPM endpoint.
Probably that's not working.
Just make sure I'm getting the right update
error message.
It's over the past CPI error now is
saying
yeah. Okay. So the path is important here.
There's a log.
Alright.
Let's try and do something interesting.
So
okay. So now we've got engine x serving
as static assets.
We got PHP serving another PHP application.
We've got our database working.
For development environment, we have an interactive D
shell, which is over
here.
So as I change my PHP code, I
can run composer command if I need to
to cache clears.
Do we have a development environment
that'll work?
Yes? Yeah. I think so.
If you were a front end developer,
you might want to
have some clever watch magic going on, but
it it works.
Should we pivot towards production?
Just thinking about the time available.
Because this is very devy, isn't it?
Yes.
This is a development environment. So
And be interesting to talk about how we'd
build the NPM stuff
for prod.
Okay.
I just let's just make sure it was
semantic a few times. So, like, what I
don't mind. This development environment would be
let's say I wanna do database migrations.
Maybe make
just wanna make sure that people understand that
that is the way that I would work.
If I were to change my database where
do migrations work? Yeah.
Cool.
If I were to change one of these
files, my development workflow would be that I
know from this environment,
just run these commands,
and it worked. Wow.
That seats is complaining. We know that already
have seats, but that's not idempotent.
So
maybe it's only run the migration.
I don't understand how the seats work in
Laravel. I'm
just gonna remove it. There must be a
a clean command. Right? After then.
P d y.
Let's see.
That work.
Yeah.
Okay. That's better.
What about tests? How do you run tests
in PHP?
There's an Test?
It has some test targets, I think.
It's basically PHP unit stuff
with some extensions for Laravel.
Test agreeing.
Lots of tests.
Okay. So the I think the development environment
is fine. We could definitely clean up the
asset stuff. But, yeah, let's talk about the
production aspects of this and then
push Alex to comment on the screen so
you can do a migrate fresh seat.
Seems like it's a bit nicer. Okay.
So how do you want to deploy this
to production in QN?
Well, you tell me. So
what's different? Right? What's different is that the
the composing store would take place in we're
not gonna have as many volume mounts.
Right? We're we're gonna do the composer install
inside the PHP side of things.
We're gonna copy the files into the images
instead of mounting them in.
And we would need we'd want to build
those assets without having to as part of
the image build. So that's a question.
It depends how we want to serve the
static assets.
Like, do you want an engine NGINX image
with them baked into the NGINX?
Maybe in real life, you'd be pushing them
to some sort of CDN
instead.
Yeah. Both are very
both are good workflows.
So the the the challenge is just
everyone should build an engine x image with
the assets. We would ship them together as
a deployment with two containers and a pods
and probably share the same tag
so that they're always deployed together.
But we can talk about that, and then
we can also talk about the CDN approach
where as part of your CI pipeline, you
would just push them
to a CDN and then ship your PHP
image with,
you know, the correct
URLs, whatever. So Well, actually, I think I
think there's two NGINXs.
There's two roles for NGINX
in this in this app. Right? One role
is serving static images,
which doesn't necessarily have to be
static files. Doesn't necessarily have to be in
the same pod as the
PHP application. Right?
The the other NGINX role is
So I I I would just because
they have to be deployed together
in a sense there because the static assets
that are deployed to NGINX
would be very unique to that build and
wouldn't install like you would run older version
of the assets with a newer version of
your PHP and FPM stuff. So for that,
I would deploy them as a deployment with
two
containers.
Yeah. I think I think that's very much
then depends on the application and the teams
involved. Right?
If you've got
yeah. It's that Conway's Law thing where the
structure of your teams determines the structure of
your application. If you've got different people in
a if you've got a detached front end
and back end workflows where maybe
there's a single page application
is the is the app
and the PHP
back end is like an API that it
hits.
They may well be separately deployable
because the fact those two groups are working
separately would mean the API would have to
stay super stable,
whereas the front end team could iterate quickly
and make lots of changes. Right? On
the other hand, if you're talking like a
traditional PHP lamp stack team where there's a
couple of front endies and a few back
endies and they're all working together on the
same stream of features,
then yes, a % you'd want to be
deploying them together because they wouldn't have had
to bake into their
way of working the fact that the API
has to be forwards compatible, backward compatible. They'll
break stuff all the time
in a coordinated way.
So which one should we which version should
we pick?
So so in that separated out team, right,
you might have the
front end assets being completely deployed
to either a CDN,
different set of static image static servers
static asset servers
to when the deploys to the PHP back
end are going. And in that case, you
might not even need NGINX for the PHP.
I mentioned it to you that that
I didn't know about this before. Someone called
mentioned
that Kubernetes
can have, like, an in NGINX ingress
point.
So you ship your PHP you ship your
FPM
and sort of trust Kubernetes to
expose that to the world,
which wouldn't work for static static assets.
But if you have this if it's a
microservice
and doesn't have any static assets, maybe that's
a good
option.
Okay.
So we we let's pick a pick a
pick an approach for this app.
Alright. So what we're gonna do is we're
gonna create an op directory,
and we're gonna start creating our Kubernetes manifest.
We'll try and tackle a few of those
different scenarios that you mentioned. So
I see their deployment. We'll call this a
ping CRM.
And we're gonna
and what that will go to you. So
I think
because the CDN bet is not something that
could show up right now, we can definitely
talk about that. Although, there's only one thing
that changes in the deployment pipeline. So let's
go with the approach in that. We have
two containers in the deployment.
One is running NGINX, one is running FDM.
For our demo, NGINX will have the assets
and we'll build an image specifically for that,
and we'll see how we deploy them together.
But at the same time, in your CI
system, you can just not deploy the engine
x one and just have a make CDN
target that does whatever your CDN target is.
Yeah. So I think this is the best
way for now, which means that we're gonna
have an image called ping CRM, and we'll
call this engine
engine x, and we'll give it a version
of latest,
which I would not recommend you do.
I just wanna
Yeah.
I don't understand what latest is. I thought
I did at one point, and then all
my illusions got busted.
We'll have that FPM.
And now we need to build these.
We also need to make the ports available.
So ports.
Internet to less than 80.
Less than 9,000.
Now we need to build the images. So
let's assume this make fail is also our
CI,
which means that we want to build
NGINX
stuff and build
FPM stuff.
Let's start with
let's get NGINX delivering assets first. So if
we come into our deployment,
let's remove let's just comment out at the
end, and let's just get this working first.
Yep. That may fail. We can just say
that we want to build an image,
and we're gonna call this ping CRM
engine x latest.
We're gonna need to target here because we're
building engine
x,
and that's gonna be an echo one for
now so that it doesn't break when I
run it.
I mean, if it's satisfied, it's build set.
So we're gonna continue to use our multilayer
build. And what we're gonna see here is
that from
Engine note well, we just need Wow.
We need to what we need to compile
the assets first.
Yeah.
Yeah. I think 10 maybe an image. Yeah.
Assets,
those
we need to be able to distribute them.
So you're right with the engine expert.
We'll just leave that as a tag,
and this is gonna be our
engine expert that we actually target.
What we want to distribute here comes from
our
tool capture line,
Asset build,
and we need to copy something to file
w w HTML.
Like that?
Yeah. This is totally how we do it.
We What we need to do is make
our code available in the build let build
set,
and we wanna run n p m c
I.
And the dependencies. Yeah.
What what I found is that
front end build stuff is much less likely
to have any sort of system dependency. So
you can you can just use the use
the node container straight off
Mhmm. You know, without having to like, we
have the PHP of how to install a
bunch of extensions and system stuff. You don't
really get that with it.
Yeah. I would expect
that to work. The only thing I wanna
check is does MPM run dev. I don't
know if they have a specific
production task that maybe does minimizing and, yeah,
prod.
So
let's call that the production one.
I may make it slightly difficult
to validate, but we'll see what happens. And
then we're gonna copy this from slash code.
Yes. It's gonna be in public.
Yep.
Yeah.
So we could be a bit more sophisticated
if we wanted to dig in about which
files we're copying in.
Mostly
from a cache invalidation point of view.
So that that node
build target
is ephemeral.
Right? It's gonna it's gonna get built. It's
gonna do all the compilation, and then we're
kind of throwing it away. We're not gonna
use it for anything. We're gonna just copy
the final assets
out. But so
in terms of image size, you're not too
worried about copying everything in, but the cache
will be invalidated anytime you change any file
at the moment. So you'd probably only copy
the files in that you knew
had to be there for the NPM build.
Oh, yeah. That's Yeah. We we don't we're
not gonna do that now because we we're
not gonna dig in and figure out which
ones.
Is it just a resources directory? We can
we can we'll give that a shot. And
if it isn't, we'll just Yeah.
You're definitely right. Like, we'd probably only need
And then package
JSON
in the root. I think you can do
this syntax. Right? You
can just
you don't need to do that. You just
you list them out. You have multiple items,
and the last one is the type the
place to put them.
Right. Oh,
maybe do multiple lines.
Are you not not pressure network. Let's test
it.
Docker
no. We're gonna use our CI.
Build assets
for Internet.
I'm slightly concerned it will lose the directories
things we're in
under code. It'll lose the some of the
structure.
Actually, it makes sense to have multiple lines
sometimes if things are gonna change at different
cadences.
Yeah. The package dot JSON probably better be
copied on first. Yeah.
So there you are. That's project is using
some sort of
lock validation, which I generally discourage,
but
I'm not gonna stick with it for now.
So you wouldn't use that if you're using
Docker. Right?
As we I
I would. For sure.
It just gives you
consistency guarantees that you don't particularly require.
So you do require, but Docker gives you.
Right. Right. Right.
So we're using
build kit when you're in a Docker,
but Compose doesn't do that yet.
No. It doesn't.
Webpack dot mix. We need that. I'll add
that and run it again. And then if
doesn't work, I will add everything for now.
Yeah.
What the heck?
What's that code called?
Dot mix dot j s or something.
It's .mix.js.
Tailwind.
Yeah. I think we
let's just copy everything. Last
one. Views Last one. Views you've got the
idea of what we're doing. Right?
It happier?
No. Okay. Give me something.
Alright. I'll copy everything.
Yeah. Please. Something something that annoys me about
NPM is it shows things as errors that
are just sort of more like warnings.
It always seems to when I'm building stuff.
I thought you're not enough to really
to really know.
Still has to run n p m update.
That's interesting.
Okay. Now what we have here
CRM,
NGINX, latest.
Let's just go ahead and save to this
container.
I w l l h t m l.
And there is all of ourminified.com.
Cool.
Should there be directories?
No.
Yeah.
It's it's like my star here is is
probably not what we want. What we wanna
do is copy.
Let's try that one more time.
I think it's gonna start flatten the directory,
which we don't want.
Yeah.
And
that's invalidated the
copy
because we edited the Docker file.
We shouldn't have
so we need Docker ignore. Right?
Well, no. Because I changed
oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah. If I had done a Docker
ignore to ignore the Docker file, but yeah.
It should be okay. Alright.
Let's see what we have in this directory
now.
That's better. Perfect.
Okay.
Looks good.
Alright. Let's deploy
that.
I know you may have the Kubernetes disabled,
I think.
And we could have excluded the index PHP
as well. Right? If we're just gonna have
just the stuff that's.
Well, that wouldn't be that. Like, if we
if we were gonna spend the time to
work out the only time we need the
copies,
we'd have been better. But because we're just
trying to get this working and not stream
for three hours to happens
Oh, I'm we should put this.
Okay.
Right now, let's let's get that quickly enabled.
I disabled it for yesterday's stream. We were
looking at the latest version of Kubernetes,
and this is an older version, so I
have to
let's see. So
Kubernetes apply.
It's We're just gonna apply it with the
engine x container to make sure that we
can pull those assets.
You still there? Yeah. That was good.
Okay. So we have a Kubernetes.
One Kubernetes.
Or
one Kubernetes. Who knows?
Everyone get pods.
Appointments.
It's just a bit slow. There we go.
Image pull back off. That's okay. Let's fix
that.
Image pull policy at not
present.
Right.
So we'll only pull it if it doesn't
have it already.
Yeah. So when you locally build images, it
can be a bit frustrating, but the default
policy is always, which means it tries to
go and pull the image. So if it's
working on the official registry for this, but
at this local label, we're gonna set them
up to do that, which means
that that runs.
So I'm gonna put forward to it
on port eighty eighty.
And if I hit
here,
you get engine x. But really what we
wanna see is
what was it?
CSS.
CSS. CSS.
It won't be called app CSS anymore because
I bet you it's minimized.
So let's just
go and check that out again.
What is that? I
think that's the debugging again.
Mhmm. Let's go ahead and save it to
pod.
Alright. I know it's around.
Yeah. Did
we copy in the config file? Or have
we mounted in the config file?
That is a good point.
Let's fix that.
We did not. Please Please
in the default one.
Etch.
I would have spent ages working on that.
Build it from here, so I've got my
old complete. Where is my build?
Image
build target
engine x.
We're calling it
n c r m engine x later.
I really need to stop abandoning that cache.
Hopefully,
it's the last time we have to build
it.
And then we'll
delete the pod, force it to restart. Hopefully,
that is enough for us to hit app
dot CSS.
Then we build Laravel
and deploy.
It'll be good. We'll get there.
When I'm debugging like this, I often make
sure I put my stuff at the bottom
of the Dockerfile even though even if it
would logically be better
higher up.
Yeah. I should have done that. And when
it works, resync on it. Resync it and
hit build and more coin and get a
cup of tea.
Why have we got crash it back off?
That upstream PHP doesn't exist.
And that's because in production, we're not using
an upstream PHP.
So
just create a v host prod
Mhmm.
Where we're gonna use
Rawkode.
I'll come into our Dockerfile.
We've had many change of how to rebuild
this image.
This is my first stream that's when post
two hours.
Yeah.
Is that good or bad?
As far as people find it valuable, it's
good. Right? I don't mind debugging things, I
think.
So I think it depends on your viewpoint
when you're watching something like this. You either
learn from seeing people debug or you get
frustrated.
Yeah. I'm sure we'll get both kind of
audio. Both
our audience will have both. This will make
it different from a slick presentation, isn't
You get to see the frustration.
Yeah. Frustrated.
Definitely frustrated.
We get to see that even Rawkode has
to debug things and makes typo.
I'm sure I make more typos in debugging
than most. I break things a lot.
Alright. So we're doing this part to force
the new image to come into play. Hopefully,
that removes our failing.
Correct? We're gonna do the port forward once
before
And see at m eighty eighty eighty eighty.
We have our CSS being delivered.
Yes. And we'll just ignore that.
Yeah. That's better. That's just cash. Okay. So
it's now trying to forward
this request to FPM and it's failing. Mhmm.
We need to add our second container to
the deployment manifest.
We want this,
which means we need to add a CI
for ping CRM FPM.
So let's copy this
FPM. And we're gonna target FPM,
which means we now need a new layer.
We'll call us Put it up near the
other PHP ones.
Alright?
Put it up near the other PHP ones.
Right.
It's always a bit I always find it
a bit weird having the notes left, you
know, a lot of different
images in one Dockerfile, at least put the
ones that are PHP, FPM together.
Alright. Okay. So we wanna from we're gonna
do a copy dot code
partner
code.
We could probably
We wanna do the composure install?
Yeah.
Before you copy code.
So it's build FPM.
Mhmm.
And then from build FPM,
we'll do a test layer,
which we're just gonna have to run the
echo test for that.
And then we'll do it from build f
p m
f p m. So this is our production
image.
And what we want is
copy.
Yeah.
Well, the vendor
I think we could just copy everything from
slash code to slash code, and then just
shut that image.
Oh, okay.
So the
build FPM,
you should swap you should move the copy
of everything till after composer install.
Yep. And so we can leverage our cache
to go.
And we probably want to do composer install
dash o.
Does that say? Optimizes
the auto loader.
The dash o what? Sorry.
Optimizes
the auto loader.
Okay.
Slightly faster. And Okay. There's there's no dev
or dash dash prod, I think it is.
Yeah.
Prod. So it won't install the dev dependencies
like PHP unit.
Okay.
That's right, isn't it? Not having the test.
Our
test run is just make we'll just stick
it in anyway.
Let's see what happens. So let's go back
to our make fail,
and we're gonna build FPM.
The parts will run our tests, which just
means using a different target. So
Yeah.
Can you please check
the location we're copying the code into on
the FPM container is the same as the
volume
we were using in Docker Compose.
Yep.
And in the FPM.
Okay.
Let's
we're happy with the next. We're gonna run
make, which is our fake CI,
spells at PM.
This would be our production
PHP
CI step.
And we got our extensions going, composer install.
I mean, this is probably gonna take, what,
one and a half minutes.
You got a joke for me, Kita?
What's really loud and sounds like a dog?
Go on. A dog.
It's a dad joke.
Any compulsory.
And another thing I would maybe do here
is just I know I go a bit
crazy adding the layers and this file will
become a little bit difficult to to read.
Because it'd be nice if this are text
highlight and recognize the from and make these,
like, rainbow highlighting in some fashion. Well, like
collapsible things.
Yeah. Or collapsible.
But as I I would probably encapsulate some
of this, like, requiring composer
and and provide, like, a CI layer or
something like that. But
for now, I am okay with that. Prod
doesn't exist in layer.
So
It's with the FPM. Oh,
I said no at first.
K.
The outline is that our CI would run
the tests,
then ship the image off to a registry.
So there's there's a couple of ways I
I do this.
There's a different types of tests, and you
can talk about that if you if you
want. What I normally do is for unit
tests is make them part of the image
build process.
Mhmm. And so that the build just stops
if you give a test field. There's no
point shipping an image anywhere.
Yep. And and then once I've got once
the unit test pass and I have an
image that works,
I then use that as a target for
my acceptance tests or end to end tests
or anything like that. It's a bit more
complicated, isn't it? Because I don't
I don't want to have the
unit testing tools in my image.
No. They wouldn't be in the image. You
would do that as part of the orchestration.
So you would run the image with an
overwrite with an entry point that you inject
into it that installs the mess and dependencies
that you need and so forth. Right. Right.
Yeah. That makes sense. So I've I've done
something similar where we we build
what did we do?
We built the prod image,
and then we built another target off it
that added
the
unit tests,
and its entry point was the tests, which
is different to what you're saying. You're saying
run the test as part of the build.
Maybe the last step of the build.
Yeah. Just because it's big enough.
And then there's all your acceptance tests, which
aren't, you know, the non unit tests
that you would then run on the after
you've built the image,
you then run a set of acceptance tests
on it before you push it out to
the registry,
which should be things like AI level tests
or
browser automation if you wanna do a little
bit of that.
Or
Why is this failing?
I didn't see the error message. What was
it?
It's saying I got a PDO.
But I do
In base.
Then you're extending from base.
Let's see the error message again.
So that's something you added to compose the
JSON.
So it's quite possible we've typoed it, but
it might be x dash p d o
underscore minus Oh, yeah. F s o underscore.
Yeah.
No. Right.
Show the camera.
Any more dad jokes?
No.
There's a comment in the chat from Robert's
Rawkode.
My wife always says, what's the prob what's
the problem of upping the project and serving
it to the public? I should show this
stream to her.
The part of actually seeing buttons and forms
running is crumbs. Debugging and getting things to
work takes most of the time. I I
agree with that.
Yeah. Definitely.
Development is 90%
debugging.
And, actually, I think in it, it's quite
an issue
that a lot that a lot of people
don't like doing it because it leads people
to only ever write new code on nice
greenfield projects.
And the real valuable stuff is sometimes, like,
bashing your head against the wall
till you figure it out
and being comfortable in that mindset.
Yep.
Well, that build just failed there because we
don't have git.
So I've added git.
Oh, you need git for composer, if that
makes sense. Yeah. We did.
I have excited the composer installed locally, which
means we never had to see see why
you shouldn't run any of the commands on
your local machine because
you need to confirm that automation works. Yeah.
We didn't do composer install in your d
shell, did we?
We did. But because all these dependencies were
there, it didn't ever have to shell exec
out to the git command.
Whereas in this environment,
does.
That's an interesting one.
Okay. That's a good point. The Docker
the Docker ignore file should have the vendor
directory.
So it's never shipped with the context for
clean builds
and node modules.
Docker Speed it all up. Right?
Node modules.
It's called vendor. Yeah. Vendor. Yeah.
Docker file.
Everything we keep editing.
Everything.
There's probably some
cash stuff.
What else do we not need?
Storage.
Database?
Yeah. We won't put it up for now.
But once this builds,
hopefully, the test pass in the image,
we can add this we can deploy the
Kubernetes deployment again, have those containers running side
by side.
Oh, it's complaining. We don't have the ZIP
extension.
Hopefully, it still passes, but we'll see.
I'll start that just now anyway.
So
and I
believe that actually needs
the
oh, no. It's just a command.
If you do prefer dist, it won't need
that.
So it needs to zip it because for
some dependencies, it'll download
download a tarball
of the release.
Oh.
You force it to always do a Git
clone,
which might isn't what you want on prod.
Alright.
Because that would also
there's a git attribute that excludes things. Right?
Mhmm.
And that's used to exclude things from the
tarball version.
So some dependencies will end up shipping you
their unit tests and their documentation and stuff
if you force this. If you prefer So
the dev command was available in the extension
extension before I started this build. It wouldn't
have pulled with the get anyway. So
Yes. I think it might be falling back
to doing a clone in all those instances
and it'll be fine. Yeah. I think it
is.
But may but I don't know. I don't
know. Maybe you don't care about whether that's
in your image or not.
I know some people who have their own
scripts
post
you know, compose a post install scripts that
goes through and deletes loads of stuff from
the vendor folder
to keep the package size down,
tests and that sort of thing.
Oh, this is slow.
Should have used
Composer two. Hang on.
Yeah. Don't know if it's in the Docker
image yet, but it does parallel downloads.
Hopefully, it won't be long.
We're close. We're almost there.
I mean, once we get this once we
get this deployed, you know, that this code
is all available.
So get that
that's Rawkode,
PHP examples.
So Docker Kubernetes is the well, I haven't
pushed it. This is the slim stuff from
last week,
which is now on a slim directory.
And I will push all of this code
with the Laravel directory or the Peng CRM
directory.
And I think maybe another good session for
another time would just be maybe cleaning this
up and and optimizing it for production.
I don't think we're gonna have to to
change to
to do that today, but we will get
it working.
There's a lot involved in containerizing and deploying
something to Kubernetes. It's it's nontrivial.
We've only been doing it for half an
hour.
Might be interesting to deploy it to some
cloud somewhere
in a future session,
work through some issues,
pick a cloud.
Well, I mean, I work for a cloud,
so we'd have to use them, obviously.
So we use different. We'd
use a diff
but that's the promise of Kubernetes. Right? Is
that you can
deploy to whichever cloud
you fancy.
Oh, yeah. Totally.
I mean, Kubernetes is an API. And if
you deploy to that API, the cloud becomes
irrelevant unless
you're consuming some managed services. In which case,
of course, you're gonna get a a level
of vendor lockout with each cloud. Yeah.
But the the Kubernetes API being your deployment
API gives you that freedom to move clouds
if you wish and take out managed services
where needed.
Or as you said last week, just do
a Heroku deploy and
skip all that. I know you're saying that
sarcastically,
but
there's a lot of small teams don't need
to be doing this stuff.
No. No. Just yeah. If you're looking at
Kubernetes, I'd hope that you're deploying more than
a Laravel application.
Yeah. More than we're deploying today.
Because you can I mean, this repository's got
a profile in it, so you can
just push it to a cloud provider?
This is really slow. That's over five minutes
now.
So should we think about why max is
slow?
Well, that's not why this is slow. This
in this instance, though. Right? Because
Oh, yeah. This is just This is just
the build context,
which is a
tarzip of the directory excluding the Docker ignore
files sent to the Docker engine and the
virtual machine. So this is just slow because
composers
I mean, we are using the get option
because that wasn't available, which it probably has
thrown it down.
Failed.
No.
So why is it failed?
So Doing the database.
So
that's the class map
optimizer that runs at the end.
Having a problem.
Why did I have a problem, Kino? Why?
Hey. That isn't a file or a c.
It isn't a folder or
Fold the raw file. Weird.
It should be we copied every oh, no.
We haven't copied the code in yet. So
the optimizer requires
the code to be there.
Yeah. Just take out the dash o then.
What we can do
take out the dash o there.
But we have to rerun all anyway because
this step failed. But take out the o
anyway because this is the way you should
do it. Take out the o at that
step. Then optimize it later. And then after
the dump auto loaded dash o
as a second step,
which I think is better in terms of
cache and validation.
Well, let's just hope this is much faster
with that zip
binary available.
Otherwise, you've got five minutes of dad jokes
to tell.
I have to go soon.
I can leave you to finish the stream
again.
Oh, you should've you should've put the ZIP
on a separate line.
Just like the population of the yeah. Those
are quick, though. I mean, that's gonna be
done in ten seconds.
It's been running for twenty six seconds.
See. See. Pretty quick.
Hopefully,
this is much faster. That it doesn't have
to go with the GitHub API.
Yeah. And I've noticed some people who
are
making this a lot faster even in the
uncached state by doing things like sharing the
composer cache as a volume
and using cache
cache from
to point to in it the previous image,
which has its composer cache populated and that
sort of magic.
So there are ways of speeding up composer
install.
Yeah. Definitely.
It's a good way to do it. Using,
like like, the cache from this very handy
for stuff like that.
We're committed we're committed now. So
Like, why is it still updating dependency? I
mean, it's not even at the fetch stage
yet, is it? Oh, there we go.
Yeah. So these installs are probably the zips.
Yeah. These are much faster. You can see
it blazing through this time.
And one of the improvements in Composer too
is that resolution
step is faster much faster.
And I guess even if it was using
concurrent downloads in Composer two, I don't even
think I expose
many cores to my Docker daemon on Mac.
So maybe I'd be able to take advantage
of them.
I'm assuming it does the concurrency by spinning
up multiple threads and having them each download
one. So it'd be
parallel downloads would be how many cores I
have, I guess.
It depends if it's CPU bound or network
bound.
If it's IO bound
if it if it's sort of network IO
bound, it might not matter how many calls
you're using, having multiple downloads at the same
time. I mean, at the other end of
the network.
Well,
it was faster,
but unfortunately,
the seed thing was
still doing that step.
Oh.
Why?
In composer JSON, is there a post install
hook?
Yep.
I guess that's been true as the problem.
Right?
Yeah.
It's not default flagged to one, so us
leaving the flag out hasn't helped.
It it doesn't really matter at this stage,
does it? Let's Let's just take the flag
out of the thing. Viewers
will get the point.
Oh.
But then we can't leverage the build cache
when we don't modify the composer dot JSON.
And I still think that's important. So I'm
just gonna disable the optimize and we'll do
it explicitly.
Because it's a deployment concern. I don't think
the compose of the JSON should be setting
that anyway.
I got root. I
will decide when to optimize my auto loader.
Yeah. Which means this is gonna take thirty
seconds to do update dependencies.
I don't if that was the extension thing.
So this is gonna take sixty seconds based
on the last run, but not too long.
Hopefully, it wanted to optimize on the data
loader, and it'll do it on our manual
step. You know, just so it's really clear
why we're kinda fighting with this.
Mhmm. If we had moved this line
here, we wouldn't have this problem.
But because composer install, all they need is
to run when the composer dot JSON changes.
We're trying to make sure that we leverage
the build cache. Because our composer dot JSON
probably won't change often. Which
means that we only need to do this
step
forward.
Yeah. And that done per auto loaded does
the reason it's not default is it scans
all the files for PHP classes.
And then
builds a big class map, I think.
There's a bunch of other stuff we could
do to optimize PHP, optimize FPM.
You can prewarm the build. You can prewarm
the op cache.
You can now
actually, I don't think you can do anything
to prewarm the new
preloader cache, but
other things we could do to make the
container more ready to serve stuff.
Yeah. You know, the op cache, the in
memory cache, you can give it a file
based backup
for So
then if if that file based back
file based sort of second layer cache is
present in the image, it'll start faster
on the first stop.
Good for workers.
I'm Right.
Let's just move it so we copy everything
in. We're not gonna get to the bottom
of this.
One of us can figure it out later.
It's almost therapeutic.
Right?
Maybe not quite.
Alright. I need to go in about eight
minutes.
What should what should we achieve between now
and then? We'll get this working. Let's assume
that works. So next, we need to handle
the migration step of this deployment.
Yeah. So it's just how this works. Now
there are two different approaches to doing database
migrations depending on what your your team does.
So the first one, which is probably the
easiest one to get started,
is to use something called an edit container
within Kubernetes.
It works like this. We give it a
name. We tell it the image that we
want to run. Now, it's just gonna be
our FTM one in this case.
And we can tell it to run a
command.
So I'm just gonna do echo because
we have not deployed the database to Kubernetes,
We're
running very low at time. And you can
imagine that what this was actually doing would
be
a it just go and make it won't
be there. PHP,
artisan,
DB migrate.
Now this runs in the container. You're you've
got a guarantee with the Kubernetes API that
and no containers
for lane 24 down will run until this
executes successfully.
So does that mean
in in terms of deployment,
what does that mean for downtime? How how
does that coordinate with an existing running system?
So
with our deployment in Kubernetes, we also have
access to the update strategy.
Mhmm.
Strategy.
Where I can then say rolling update, and
then I could tell the max search.
Let me just while I play this for
that.
So when we specify the strategy, we can
tell it that we're only gonna accept, you
know, one to be unavailable at any given
time. Right? Also takes percentages,
so you could say that we're allowed to
scale above
if we've got a record of score, if
we can scale above by a %, we'll
we'll watch four new months
and do the rolling upgrade that way, or
we can specify the maximum unavailable and say
that we want to do an upgrade this
way where we can we'll take one out,
deploy it, and it'll work.
This also requires
this approach requires
that your
that your migrations
either do database level locking so that you
don't have multiple containers trying to run at
the same time, or that there's gonna be
it also has to be idempotent, which is
very important. Most database migration systems are.
If you're
if you've already made the premeditated
effort that your database migrations are always gonna
be additive,
you know, you're always adding columns, which is
a really good way to handle database migrations,
Which means that your older version of the
code will still work even if the migration
hasn't run yet.
This is a really nice way of handling
this. Then you can remove
I'm just gonna comment these out so they're
available when I push the code.
Then you can remove the other container and
allow this just to deploy as
as
but before you do the upgrade in this,
you can use a job.
There's a special Kubernetes type
where we would
use a job here, and then that job
would also have a spec
where
I'm not gonna be able to I don't
think I can all complete job stuff, but
and
that let me pull up an example from
one of the helm charts that I've intend.
So I use a job in this
to configure the authentication in in FluxDP. So
you set the API version and the kind
to be job,
and then we just specify a container with
a command that we want it to run.
And that could just be a job that
spends a lot asynchronously
to you or before your deployment and runs
the migration that way. So
let me try and clarify the two different
approaches and why you need where how to
pick or how to decide which one to
pick. So
the only reason I would ever use a
job approach
would be my migrations do not do any
database locking to make sure that two don't
run at the same time.
In this case, you have to, as part
of your CI, run the job
object first,
then do a deployment update.
If you're in a position where you do
have the database locking, which I'm assuming probably
Laravel has already got sorted with the ORM,
then go with the edit container approach and
tweak your max unavailable or search depending on
the failure condition that you're going to accept
for that.
And whenever possible, regardless of approach, always try
and use additive changes in your database migration.
Yeah.
I think there's a point where you know
that
It's okay. Like, we can take that. Anyway,
like and the the cache is there, so
it should be okay. There's a there's a
point where
if you've been adding columns consistently, some of
them are now redundant and you know there'll
be a point where you know there's no
running code using that column.
So you can you can then go out
and take dump some old tables and
you can even look at even in a
massive system, you can look at some of
the access logs. This table's never been queried
in the last year.
Let's delete it.
Does it have you read the refactoring databases?
I have not.
I've got it to hand.
It's pretty good. Martin Fowler imprint.
Lots of patterns for
restructuring databases with forward and backward compatibility.
Oh, nice. Mostly involving lots of triggers.
So I was just trying to work out
why my build cache wasn't used there.
And it's because as I was talking, I
was modifying the whole directory.
Yeah. So there you go.
Oh,
we're not even but all locked. It'd probably
be ignored for the Docker. Correct. And then
that would have been cached.
And my test failed.
I'm gonna remove the test because I just
wanna get this deployed.
Can you make that? Yeah. We'll come back
to that.
My mic fail, isn't it?
Oh, it's just an absolute calamity of errors.
It's good to show,
you know, humanity.
Oh, yeah. That's exactly what it is. So
and I'm gonna assume that image is deployable
anyway because that did build in that last
one, the tests were a different step. Right?
Yeah.
No. I haven't purchased the production image because
it was targeting test when it failed, not
thing.
Alright. We just need to give it another
thirty seconds, and then we'll get the deployment
done, and we'll both be over here.
Yeah.
I think we're definitely gonna have to have
another session on this.
Yeah. Much to cover. So much to cover.
We will build on this one. Right? We'll
make it better. Oh, yeah. Yeah. We'll we'll
stick with this. Okay. So now we've got
our image built.
So I can just do a cube apply
opt Kubernetes.
Let's see.
Why is it only got one container?
Duplicating the name?
Is that okay?
I'm not sure. I've never actually
I've never tried that.
There you go. That's better. Yeah. The name
oh, because it must merge all that. Yeah.
It must flatten it. Okay.
So pill damage, and that's because I forgot
the policy on our APM one.
That's where we again,
let's just run a watcher on it. Right.
Okay. Both are running.
So in theory,
we're now at the port forwarding state again.
So two containers, one pod.
I don't know if I'm used to being
there. We're gonna get that off.
Okay.
So now the logs director needs special permission.
So
Why didn't that happen previous oh, because we
Slim is logging to standard out. So the
the problem here is that we've not configured
Laravel to log the standard out.
Why can't it find why can't it write
to that file?
I think
I'm assuming this directory doesn't exist. Let's confirm.
Is it gonna be file permissions or something
like that?
The exec into this container, we need to
specify it's the f e m one, and
we wanna run batch.
What do I call the container?
Peng c o m s.
Forage.
It is draping through it.
Does the container run its route?
It does. Yeah. We know.
I don't know. That's a log from
that's been mounted then
because there's not a Docker a Docker ignore
fail that's given that.
As
last time,
I have to go now.
I've reached the last possible point
where I can
get to my Let's just yeah. Well, let's
just call it here. Let's pick it up
again next
week from here and see how far we
get. Because like I said, we've got a
lot to cover, and there's no point in
me trying to rush it.
Yeah. We're quite close. We've got some working
images,
working containers.
They work fine for dev.
We just we've only spent
an hour trying to deploy it to production,
I think That's a reasonable time scale to
fail. Let's
do it again. Alright. Yeah. I will push
this code just now. It's available on gitlab.com/rawcode/php-examples.
Kieran and I will be back again next
week to continue our efforts to deploy a
production Laravel application on Kubernetes.
Kieran, thank you for joining me again. It
was a pleasure, and I'll see you again
next week. Bye. See you next week. Bye.